I am so honored tonight to appear with  mr. Mitchum to present the Award for  Best Supporting Actress is that what  we're doing yes and time is of the  essence all right then let's keep it  shorter than the winds of war the file  gifted women nominated for this award  are Glenn Close in the world according  to God Teri Garr and Tootsie  Jessica Lange in Tootsie  Kim Stanley in Francis  Lesley Ann Warren in victor/victoria  they were all brilliant I stand in awe  of talent and invite you to the opening  of my next picture well dear friends  thanks with ladies the winner is the  winner is Jessica Lange  this is a great honor for me I thank you  all very much  I feel really lucky to have been a part  of Tootsie to have worked with actors  like Charlie Dern and Dabney Coleman and  Terry God and to have had Sydney [ __ ]  as my director and Dustin Hoffman as my  leading lady oh this is so exciting I  want to thank you all very very much  this means so much to me thank you